the new season of one of HGTV's biggest
shows just returned flip or flop Tariq
and his ex Christina have clearly
learned how to work and co-parent
together but Tariq just revealed to our
lauren zima their divorce was his rock
bottom I was a guy that lost everything
you know I hit rock bottom you know I I
was at the lowest lowest lowest point of
my life to the point where I could
barely get out of bed making things even
harder for Tariq watching as his ex
Christina moved on she married British
TV host ant Anstead in December they
have a baby boy due next month that was
very very difficult and as you know time
heals think I didn't realize what I was
missing until I found what I was missing
so meet
tarick's new girlfriend Heather a young
they've been dating for a month she sat
in on our interview and it's clear
tarick's a Smitten Kitten she is just so
adorable I'm saying words I never
thought I would say again she's my
girlfriend but you can't help but notice
how much Heather looks like tark's ex
and get this just like Christina
Heather's a realtor and a reality TV
star she's on the Netflix show selling
Sunset introduced her to my kids last
night for the first time my mom my dad
my mom's husband my sister so so we're
doing it you know you live a block from
Christina did you tell her hey Heather's
gonna meet the kids like have you talked
to her about her we I actually no I
haven't talked to her about Heather yet
so that's probably a talk I should
probably have pretty soon like maybe
today considering like I'm talking about
it on TV now she'll probably find out I
think ya think Tarek and Christina still
work together on flip or flop he's
promoting the new season solo and it
looks like they are still struggling in
the communication department you find
out that you're pregnant do you kind of
call and give him a heads-up on big
milestones like this um I told him right
before I told the kids how did that
conversation go
call yes no shot gonna call about her
she yeah she said hey I'm just letting
you know I'm having another baby you
know and I'm kind of moving forward with
everything
oh yeah it was an unexpected call okay
hose up it was a surprise yeah this
bright I had no idea to go but no I'm
happy for them I asked you a big
question at the end here would you get
married again that is a big question yes
do you think you would have said that a
couple years ago oh no oh no I'm gonna
sell that a cup weeks ago cuz unique oh
here's ago okay sir phone flip or flop
airs Thursdays on HGTV
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]